sebastien you've mentioned before that
you had a love affair with risk where
does this currently stand
well I risk is still a very appealing
thing for a lot of people it seems to it
seems to increase your appreciation of
the moment and of life in general and it
enhances a lot of things but it also
occasionally comes at a cost and for me
that cost caught up with me in 2011 when
my good friend Tim Hetherington was
killed in Libya in combat he was killed
on an assignment that I was supposed to
be on with him the last minute I
couldn't go and he died and I was left
feeling tremendously guilty and also
keenly aware of the fact that when you
risk your life in war or anywhere else
it feels like you're just risking
something of yours your own life and
actually what you're putting at risk is
the emotional welfare of everyone you
love and I watched the the consequences
of Tim's death ripple out through his
community in the most devastating ways
and I just thought whatever the upside
of risk is personally it's not worth the
potential downside to everyone I care
about and I I mean literally within an
hour of finding out the timid died I
decided to stop covering war well you've
also said that covering war and being in
combat blows out your levels and I
thought that was a very interesting way
to put it that normal life quote unquote
is really never the same so once that
our decision came down how was it for
you to assimilate back into life I
exposure to risk absolutely does blow
out your levels and it makes everything
else look pretty dull and meaningless I
think I mean the feeling of
meaningfulness comes from feeling that
there's consequences to things and the
greater the consequences are the more
meaning something seems to have and the
ultimate consequences are life and death
and so in a combat situation everything
seems incredibly meaningful because the
enormous consequences are everywhere and
then you come back to
you know your suburban home in America
and nothing seems very meaningful
because the consequences we've made it a
society where consequences are kept to a
minimum which is great except that it
feels meaningless and I think the trick
to living happily in that kind of
situation is to find other kinds of
other kinds of meaning you know you know
while walk in the park with your child
is very meaningful but there's no risk
involved there's no consequences really
involved and I think it's a matter of
maturing of maturity to grow out of a 20
year old or a 30 year old mindset about
excitement and risk and consequence into
something a little bit more profound and
for me I don't know if I'm late or early
but I started that process in my late
40s and I'm getting there and actually
you know I think I have a certainly less
exciting life but I think I have a much
richer life emotionally richer life than
I ever could have had jetting off to war
zones and coming back all cranked with
adrenaline well I know the word courage
is a huge thing for you and then you
said that the word has changed it's
evolved what encouraged initially mean
to you and how has it manifest well it's
very interesting
I mean soldiers don't even like the word
courage in their opinion their soldiers
and there's cowards but the word
courageous soldier the phrase courageous
soldier is completely redundant they're
one in the same thing in the minds of
soldiers I think there's a kind of raw
physical courage in combat or in other
situations I think young men are wired
for that and quite good at it I think
it's all product of evolution and I
think our species dependent on depended
on something like that and it's young
men you can see the same behavior in
primates also it's very clear this is
how it came from an evolutionary past
but I think there's other forms of
courage as well as moral courage as
political courage
and I think you know basically courage
courage means standing for an ideal for
a principle regardless of the
consequences there was an amazing study
done about comparing courage between men
and women men typically their courage
takes the form of physically taking
action running into the burning building
jumping into the surf to change the
state of the child protecting their
girlfriend from bullets in a theater
where someone's shooting at them that
kind of thing women actually don't do
that very much certainly not if this men
are out well they let the men do it and
well they should wear women's courage
comes into play is a really moral
courage and during World War Two there
were there were people in Europe who
were not Jewish right they were not in
danger from the Nazis and they would
hide Jewish families in their basements
or whatever things that would absolutely
get their whole get them killed
if the Germans found out about it and
often it was women the female heads of
households not the men who were
insisting on these things it was a real
moral courage that men actually are a
little bit more ambivalent about so
there's I mean we're an incredible
species right humans and there's those
two very important forms of courage they
seem to be divided a little bit by
gender and I think both are necessary
for a safe and civil society actually if
another filmmaker
wanted to emulate what you and Tim
Hetherington have done with these two
films what would you advise to them I
think in order to repeat what Tim and I
did you have to you filmmaker would have
to understand first and foremost that
documentary film is journalism it's not
a vehicle for your opinions it's not a
public service announcement it's not a
commentary on the war or anything else
it's a documentary it's documenting the
reality if you go into that situation
any situation with a real neutrality
people pick up on that and they respect
it and they'll talk to you and the only
things him and I were interested in was
in the physical and emotional reality of
combat and other great journalists were
evaluating the war and having a
political discussion and all that very
important to and I we're not doing that
and if you want to do if you as a
filmmaker would want to duplicate what
Tim and I did you would have to find
that place in yourself where you're
really not judging you're just trying to
understand it's hard to do but I think
it's a crucial part of the it's a
crucial part of the work done by the
media is to under just understanding the
basic reality terms what some people are
going through yeah I think thank you
very much